[Música]
a
escala en parís
aída palau
bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio francia internacional y de france
24 hoy les invitamos a conocer a una
escritora y filósofa que con tan sólo 21
años ha publicado ya cuatro libros es
muy mediática en españa' con decenas de
miles de seguidores en las redes fue tal
vez a pesar de ella portavoz del
colectivo trans y es una voz que cuenta
muchísimo en el análisis de la política
española actual hoy hace escala en parís
elizabeth duval elisabeth muchísimas
gracias por estar con nosotros y
bienvenidas muchas gracias a vosotros
por invitación bueno elizabeth ahora
vive en parís donde está estudiando en
la sorbona y en españa es muy conocida
también tiene seguidores en américa
latina pero me gustaría que se nos
dijera quién es el is habitual es bueno
un ejercicio un poco reductor lo
reconozco pero bueno vamos a hacerlo
igual quién es elizabeth dugard bueno yo
creo siempre en muchas entrevistas o en
muchos periódicos cuando
se ponen en escribirme hacer un amalgama
de etiquetas y etiquetaje que me
interesa muy poco me interesa más
definirme por lo que lo que hago que
bordado serie de cosas con lo cual de
todas las categorías me quedaría con
escritora porque escribo y me dedico a
escribir bueno ha sido como muy madura y
muy precoz en todo lo decíamos en la
presentación cuatro libros y tan solo
tiene 21 años siendo adolescente le dijo
a sus padres que era una chica pero
estaba en un cuerpo de chico
y adquirió mucha notoriedad en españa
fue la cara visible del movimiento trans
desde muy joven pero en su libro ensayo
después de lo trans muestra un poco su
hartazgo no es como decir bueno pongo
punto y final a esta a esta etapa hasta
el de lo trans dice porque se cansó
de ser portavoz o activista o militante
hay un momento en relación con las
identidades relación con lo transistor
lo trató en después de lo trans cuando
habló de la noción de tolerancia en
pasolini en el que parece que no somos
capaces de ver al otro más allá de su
diferencia o más allá de aquello que
hace que el otro para nosotros sea
diferente no vemos una persona trans con
una persona que tiene en general y no
somos capaces de ver que es algo más ya
del hecho de que sea trans o que se
aleje antes de publicar después de
lograr su público otros dos libros reina
y excepción que no tienen que ver con la
temática trans y sin embargo en
entrevistas o muchas veces simplemente
porque la temática trans suscita cierto
interés mediático cuando hacía
entrevistas sobre esos dos libros me
preguntaban mucho sobre sobre el tema
trans no con lo cual en parte por ese
hartazgo yo decidí escribir después de
lo trans como una manera de zanjar el
asunto es decir que me desvinculaba de
aquello que había sido de esa portavocía
de tener que representar o cargar yo en
mis espaldas con el peso de un colectivo
y que quería hacer otras cosas porque lo
que yo me dedico al final es a la
literatura y a la filosofía que son
disciplinas que no solamente tienen que
tratar lo trans lo que llegó despertado
también es que me jubilo de alguna
manera
de hablar de lo tras lo cual no quiere
decir que deje del todo de ser activista
militante quizás no de lo trans no pero
el análisis político o la implicación en
la actividad política tiene su parte
también de otro tipo de militar por eso
deja madrid y se instala en parís
buscando un poco el anonimato para nada
es un factor más de unas coordenadas que
hacen que acaben
viviendo en la actualidad en parís es un
factor más realmente la gran explosión
de
que la gente me conozca y me reconozca
en las calles de ciudades de españa
sucede hace no tanto tiempo como de un
año y medio para acá más o menos no
después de publicar reina y después de
que se acabe el el primer confinamiento
pero antes de eso podía pasar pero en
muy raras ocasiones realmente si se
acaba me parecía mucho que ver con con
carambolas y contingencias y azares
vitales que son al final lo que acaba
llevando a una la pierna ciudad pero era
que procura tal vez un anonimato
bastante placentero
bueno leído en alguna entrevista que
decía ser trans no significa mucho en mi
vida bueno estábamos comentando no es de
este aspecto hace hace nada y me gustó
esta frase porque yo siempre pensado que
porque una persona trans tendría que
hablar de lo trans no sólo de su
condición de trans el luego me dirán que
a lo mejor lo estoy pensando desde
una
un lugar muy cómodo de mujer
heterosexual blanca europea pero sí que
parece que vivamos una época en la que
el feminismo solo puede hablar
feministas o mujeres del racismo sólo
pueden hablar los negros es una época un
poco extraña tal vez peligrosa no sé qué
opina
al mismo tiempo que me parece razón de
shannon decir esto de que lo trans no
ocupa ese espacio en mi vida pero que
tengo que reconocer que ha hecho de que
no lo ocupe no es una posición de cierto
privilegio no viene marcada una opción
de privilegio porque tengo la voz
mediático porque puedo dedicarme a hacer
tanto a tantas otras cosas que quizás y
carecer otros factores seguramente no
podría hacer en después del otras
también yo hablo de esto último que
comentaba si lo trato llamándolo la
posición identitaria en el discurso de
aquello que no afecta a la identidad de
uno mismo de aquello que no atraviesa la
mentira de uno mismo parece que se pone
en el dogma la normativa de que no se
puede hablar
o no se debe hablar no creo que muchas
veces quizá vayan a tener mucho más
sentido las opiniones de alguien que ha
pasado por algo que los dejen que no lo
conoce pero sin embargo uno de los
términos para que la discusión pública o
el ágora después un pública esté más o
menos abierto es que todo pueda ser
debatido y que todo puede ser batido
también implica que dejemos lugar a
cosas que pueden ser banales no tiene
sentido y cosas que sí lo tienen me
gustaría tener su opinión sobre la
cultura de la cancelación
la cultura de la cancelación es un
estadounidense pero se ha importado a
europa y más concretamente a francia y
algunos ejemplos en los que se han
anulado funciones por ejemplo en los que
aparecían blancos pintados de negro no
sé qué opinión tiene usted de la cultura
de la cancelación y si se ha importado a
francia se está exagerando hay ejemplos
puntuales esto bahamas ha llegado tarde
pero para instalarse creo que en francés
muchas veces esto es una cosa muy
francesa grito decirlo después de cuatro
años viviendo viviendo aquí hay una
especie de
aversión a todo aquello que provenga de
eeuu en la cual se concibe todo lo que
viene de eeuu con una especie de
invasión viral o bacteria que contra la
cual en lo francés tiene que producir
sus anticuerpos no no hay nada bueno que
pueda venir de eeuu y si un término
encuentra su origen en eeuu encontramos
que es lo peor del mundo y que combatirá
a toda costa creo que eso lo trata muy
bien dice elsa vigo
que expreso ahora en la col de su
tensión social en su libro sobre hay que
separar a otro y la obra creo que no se
puede comparar la situación exacta que
hay en francia en eeuu en relación con
con esto y que en todo caso lo que puede
permitirnos una importación de
ciertos términos del debate al mundo
francés son visiones más complejas más
profundizadas con más matices sobre el
mundo
artístico sobre la moral reflexión sobre
a que tiene derecho una persona a nivel
también jurídico fuera de que sea un
artista y si le permitimos a los
artistas cosas que los de personas no
les permitimos no no creo que haya
realmente todavía por ahora en francia
un problema con la cultura de la
cancelación en su último libro es una
novela no es un ensayo madrid será la
tumba en la editorial española lengua de
trapo y es la historia de amor y de
deseo en madrid entre dos chicos uno
pertenece a un grupo de extrema derecha
otro pertenece a un grupo de extrema
izquierda en el relato vemos muchísimas
contradicciones entre estos
protagonistas
y ramiro
y hay un aspecto muy importante en el
libro habla de dominique baneado del
reino cambio que son figuras de la
extrema derecha francesa hay mucho de
francés en este libro aunque pase algo
que suceda en madrid y que defienden una
teoría del complot no cambió idea por la
cual se está abriendo un plan en francia
para sustituir a la población blanca por
magrebíes y por africanos y es una
teoría que está muy muy de actualidad
porque la retoma uno de los candidatos
presidenciales en francia el de extrema
derecha el ix de move
y pone de relieve como la extrema
derecha actual está seduciendo a los
obreros los está convenciendo
de que puede haber esa sustitución esta
gran sustitución de población porque
cree que está calando tanto el discurso
entre los obreros y también entre
atención entre los jóvenes en la extrema
de la extrema derecha tanto en españa
como en francia el tipo de discursos que
antes eran discursos muy minoritarios de
los que abiertamente se consideraba que
eran teorías del complot sin ningún tipo
de base en los está incorporando a lo
que es la esfera pública y con eso está
convirtiendo el debate y el terreno del
debate en algo mucho más tóxico de lo
que se ha visto nunca nunca antes igual
que sucede cuando por ejemplo se está
alimentando de forma y ferviente ya no
duda sino un discurso
antivacunas complotista que va muy
ligado a la extrema derecha la parte de
la población obrera sobre todo una
francia es industrializada que ha
sufrido las consecuencias peores o más
negativas de la globalización no creo
que sea tanto la que se ve seducida por
porsche - sobre todo porque las bases de
no son tan obreristas o la base
electoral de ese modo tiene más que ver
con una derecha tradicionalista que
realmente ejemplifica los polos entre
los que se está moviendo la esma derecha
contemporánea no también en españa en el
caso de box tenemos un componente más
tradicional o un componente de clases
más altas de una tracción también de
miembros dentro del estado contra una
parte de la izquierda y luego una
tentativa de acercamiento nativista a
los obreros muy relacionada con el
discurso que aparece muestra la tumba de
los españoles primero y ese discurso
cuando una parte de esa población puede
sentir que la izquierda la ha abandonado
puede llegar a calar bien injustamente
de parte de culpa tiene la izquierda en
todo esto yo creo sobre todo en por
ejemplo en la desaparición de la
izquierda francesa en relación con las
elecciones a quien habría que analizar
para encontrarla la culpa es el canal de
defensa
y lo que hay que comparar entre francia
y españa para comprender qué parte de
culpa se tiene es entre fon solondz y el
gobierno actual entre los y unidades
podemos si la izquierda no cumple sus
promesas o si la izquierda gobierna como
gobernaría a la derecha que la gente no
tenga confianza o no crea en lo que haga
la izquierda es una cosa completamente
natural pero no cree que los ha
abandonado también en según qué debates
de sociedad frente a
discursos o sea que se ha apoderado la
derecha de algunas preocupaciones de los
obreros ya no sólo que no haya cumplido
sí pero esas preocupaciones muchas veces
cuando se habla de las preocupaciones de
los obreros se ha pasado un discurso por
el cual esas preocupaciones serían
solamente económicas cuando creo que hay
que aceptar que no por decirle a un
obrero que tú vas a solucionar sus
condiciones de vida o que vas a
mejorarlas es sobre automáticamente va a
votar te sino en digamos los partidos
comunistas tenía mayoría absoluta desde
el año para boom desde hace muchísimos
años el sobre o si se ve en españa por
ejemplo en el caso de cataluña no votan
en función de su clase sino que han
votado muchas veces en función del marco
nacional y en función del marco de
oposición al independentismo pueden
votar incluso dependiendo puede haber el
obrero es muy progresistas lo cultural y
moral y puede haber logros muy
conservadores y todo eso influye dentro
del voto no lo podemos reducir el voto a
unas cuantas características y
dependiendo de sociología dependiendo un
montón de factores estos sobre los
atender a alguna otra cosa bueno nos
quedaríamos horas hablando pero ya no
nos quedan más tiempo muchísimas gracias
elisa virtual le deseamos mucha suerte y
mucho éxito con este su último libro
madrid será la tumba muchísimas gracias
gracias muchas gracias a todos ustedes
por habernos acompañado ya saben que nos
pueden seguir también internet en rc y
mundo.com en france 24 puntos con hasta
pronto amigos
[Música]
i